see youtubers it's Charlie first Black
Panther behind-the-scenes Dorma lodging
badass I also have chadwick boseman
talking about the plot and the new suits
are going to give him what you're
looking at here is the dorm Ellijay
setting up for a big action set piece
these costumes are a little bit
different than other BTS that I have
later in the video if you new to the
channel I do Marvel videos every week so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's even a giveaway that's going on
now that I'll explain at the end of the
video so you may have heard that Lupita
Nyong'o Danai gurira
from Walking Dead are playing Dora
milosh a character's think of them as a
whole team of black widows that's how
badass they are that was why it was so
funny when they had that moment in civil
war where she's like move or you will be
moved it is really briefly you see Black
Panthers eyes pop up like oh man shits
about to go down this is so great but we
don't have time for this
so let's keep going Chadwick Boseman
actually did an interview where he
talked a little bit about the plot of
the movie he referenced the Dorma logic
so here's that clip right here maybe I
can tell you even a little more that or
a little bit more I would kill mongers
is gonna be one of the villains played
by Michael B Jordan who I love Lupita
Nyong'o another actor actress that I
love it's part of the dorm Elijah Danai
gurira is also part of the dorm Elijah
so that does not give you any storyline
just telling you some of the Catholic
characters that are there and I think
you know there will be some changes from
some conflicts or the better way to fit
some criticism of panthous that that
you'll see in the Congo may be such a
menace to so if that wasn't clear
chadwick boseman is teasing black
panther vibranium suit upgrades he wears
a vibranium weave suit it looks like
cloth but it's really stronger than
steel it's stronger than iron man's
typical armor now iron man always gets
upgrade so I'd expect him to show up an
infinity war with something equally as
cool but black panther has access to
more money in more advanced technology
than tony stark does so that is why he
gets the coolest suit even though iron
man typically has the coolest toys it's
the same deal with the spider-man movie
you show up with the new stark tech suit
slowly over time over the next couple
movies you get little upgrades extra
toys it's going to be so badass
but Danai gurira actually was teasing
her character a little bit she said
she's a bit of an army woman so she's
completely devoted to black panther
Lupita's character even though she's
also a member of the dorm illogic has a
little more of an antagonistic
relationship but like chadwick boseman
said they're going to be addressing a
lot of the craziness that's happening
within Wakanda so I'll explain the
storylines but there's a lot of
Christopher priest black panther and a
lot of Tata javi coats black panther so
there's a couple comic book storylines
that we have to talk about the way
they're used as as Special Forces but
there's a ceremonial aspect to their
order
they're called the wives and training
even though none of them actually ever
really expect to get married to Black
Panther the characters that Lupita and
and I are playing are actually from a
Christopher priest run on black panther
which was kind of like the Marvel ninth
version of black panther so I don't
think they're going to be doing a ton of
story from that run if you haven't read
it it was basically an attempt to make
black panther cool again editorial felt
like sales weren't that great so they
brought Christopher priest on Joe
Quesada was the editor and they put it
under the Marvel Knights imprint and
turned him into this street-level New
York City hero so it was almost like he
was a defender for a little while so it
was kind of a
virtual run because black panther's king
of Wakanda is this big badass figure
he's an Avenger but at the time he was
sort of an outsider he'd been out
stirred from Wakanda because he'd almost
crashed the world's economy trying to
take down kill monger so everybody hated
him including Tony Stark
The Avengers kind of hated them a little
bit too because he revealed the only
reason he joined them initially was so
that he could determine that they
wouldn't be a threat to his home nation
of Wakanda so there was a lot of
retconning going on with his backstory
to make him more of an outsider
they caused him to come to New York with
some of his Durham illogic so they
daredevil DUP his title just a little
bit he got more hardcore he started
using more gadgets he got the energy
blades so it's a more violent version of
the character but it's him doing things
that you normally hadn't seen him do
like most of the time you expect to see
Black Panther in Wakanda but that's kind
of what's going on at Tata haci Coates
run on black panther actually he just
kind of finished that he's writing
another book right now but he wrote this
really great reimagining of the
character in a ways that you would
expect to see him be portrayed before he
gets his big movie so if you're new to
the character I recommend you start with
volume 6 nation under our feet it picks
up after Secret Wars so there is some
story that you might miss out on a
little bit like his sisters trapped
between life and death very clearly
they're not going to be doing that in
the movie but it does a better job of
showcasing that Dermalogica
his relationship with the tribes of will
conduct because Wakanda itself is made
up of a bunch of different cities and
then a bunch of lesser tribes so there's
a lot of warring factions within Wakanda
so in order to quell that they form the
dorm Ellijay the ceremonial group that's
meant to bring everyone together they
become the wives in training so it's all
the different peoples of Wakanda getting
representation within the highest
circles of government so none of them
actually expect to marry black panther
but they become super badass fighters
they get the best tech and if you read
that new run they actually have even
cooler suits so there's a lot of dissent
within the rank there's a storyline that
plays out where Black Panther himself
feels like this terrible King so even
some of the dorm Ellijay revolts against
him he has to deal with all these
insurgents and the really cool thing is
I was looking down the IMDB cast list I
actually spotted a character from the
new title who's one of the people
who leaves the dorm illogic so even
though there's a lot of things happening
in the new comic that they're not going
to work into the movie it does a really
good job of showing you the politics of
Wakanda the problems that he faces that
go beyond that of the Avengers and the
other stuff that's happening in the
world like even within Wakanda it's kind
of a nightmare in the way they address
their spirituality is through him trying
to save his sister there is no one
listed on the cast list as his sister so
either they're doing her stealth or
they're just not doing her at all but
you have to imagine is there going to be
black panther sequel so there'll be
plenty of time to work in all the
characters that don't make it into the
first film the movie is not coming out
until next February so it's going to be
a while before we see a teaser but I'm
expecting a whole bunch of stuff at
Comic Con let me know what you're most
excited for the Black Panther is a
pretty easy sell for Marvel fans because
he's such a badass and it's so new it's
so different from the other Marvel
characters that I think it'll add a nice
flavor to the Marvel Universe and help
the tone of Phase three so it doesn't
feel exactly like phase one or phase two
usually you do that with new characters
Black Panther is just one of the coolest
new characters in addition to spider-man
that they just introduced to the
universe what's going to happen next is
I'll post my final Iron Fist review
there were a couple problems I had with
the series that I think they can largely
fix by season two so I'll explain
everything but congratulations to the
new giveaway winner will Angel TKD you
win the Spider Man action figures please
private message me on the backend of my
channels there was a new round of the
giveaway in this video announce the
winner when I post my next Marvel video
but all you have to do to enter just be
a subscriber leave a comments on the
video real simple new iron fist
coming in a little while while you wait
for that click here for the black
panther teaser video and click here for
new guardians of the galaxy thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight